哈喽大家好我是[来源标识已去除]欢迎大家来到[来源标识已去除]出品的拼多多商家成长训练营的第一节课程流量的底层逻辑我们在做拼多多这个平台的时候呢一定要很清楚的去知道这个平台里面的流量分布是什么流量的模式是什么流量的类型以及流量各个入口的关系到底是什么很多人会说我在这个拼多多平台里面做了这么多年我对这个平台的印象就是只要低价我就能拿到流量拿到订单那么流量这个词呢其实是对所有我们
我们店铺做的数据的一种总结流量你可以理解为曝光流量点击流量咨询收藏到最后的一个转化那么你们就想过一个问题拼多多这个平台里面我们都在去宣导它是一个特别能去做店群的地方难道这个平台里面就不可以去类似于淘宝天猫一样吗做一个大店一天能做三十万五十万八十万一百万这样的个店铺在一个店铺里面去做五个款十个款二十个款能不能做到首先答案是肯定的能做到
但是这个平台里面呢会有各种的处罚 处罚完以后呢对店铺里面呢会有流量的各种的一个损失举个很简单的例子我这个店铺里面会有A加B加C每个链接的能做到五百单啊一千单以及两千单那么我的整个店铺呢一千大概一天大概能做到四千单左右那么这个时候会面临一个问题如果我的店铺里面因为A链接里面的某一个违规导致了我的店铺二级处罚
那么不好意思这两条链接也会死掉所以拼多多的整个的流量逻辑呢跟所有传统电商平台的流量全部都是不一样的这个平台的流量你可以理解为是瀑布式的流量大家想一个问题你如果是一个人站在瀑布下面你拿一个桶你去接水你是接不住瀑布冲下来的水因为它的水压和它的速度太快了所以呢整个平台的流量的分布式逻辑它其实是一小块一小块
一小块的一个流量池所以呢我们在整个拼多多里面只要去做好一个流量的核心认知就可以了在一个店铺里面尽可能的只做一个单品爆款那么有的人会去问我在这个店铺里面做了一款爆款的这个毛衣蓝式的那么我这个店铺里面可不可以去做一个蓝式的爆款的羽绒服可以去做那么你又面临了我上面去讲的这个问题如果毛衣发货出了问题发款出了问题你的羽绒服
链接可能也会死掉所以呢我们尽可能在一个店铺里面只做一个单品爆款的一个东西那么单品爆款的定义呢后面呢在整个打爆款的过程中我也会跟大家去说爆款有的人会说10单20单30单40单以及1000单到底什么样的一条链接才能称为一个爆款那每个人对爆款的定义都不是不一样那你可以根据整个平台里面对这款款式这条链接这个价位这个人群的综合的一个定单
量去经营分析一般的单品爆款的话你好歹能让一条链接啊我个[来源标识已去除]个人那个经验啊一天能销售一万块钱左右你可以称之为一个小爆款可能到了两万三万四万五万以后可能是一个大的一个爆款所以呢整个拼多多的流量是大的是非常大的一个店铺你想要做到1000万多人做到但是你要面临的一个问题这个店铺可不可以持续的经营下去长久的盈利下去
所以拼多多的整个流量，我们知道记住一个关键词是瀑布冲下来的水溅出来的小水花我们这些商家在这个小水花里面去进行咬水活所以呢它是一个瀑布式的流量这个呢就是瀑布式流量的一个原因它和淘宝天猫抖音直播短视频所有电商平台都是不一样总结一句话啊一个店铺尽可能做一个单品大爆款
那么其余的链接都是小爆款或动销也就是我们经常会在去整个店铺的产品的类型去做分层的时候去做分级的时候尤其是我一些服务的一些品牌的商家我会对他去做一些流量的分层我们会提到一个东西叫SIB
S呢是超级大爆款不管是人群呢还是订单量呢还是销售额是足以去进行扛的
大爆款那A呢是小爆款B呢是动销动销款式所以你可以给店铺里面去做分层那么有的人会去提到一个东西[来源标识已去除]你讲的是标品类目是这样的一个逻辑那么在非标品服饰配件鞋袜等等这个类目里面我的款式有很多是不是这样的一个东西呢那么你可以理解为非标品的整个类目里面大多数的链接都是小爆款因为
会随着季节款式啊时间以及人群的一个适用它会慢慢慢慢的变成衰退期的一个爆款所以呢整个流量的模式它是瀑布式的一个流量总结一句话吧尽可能一个店铺里面去做一个主推面接即可不要把问题想的过于复杂更不要在拼多多里面想要去做天猫的这种类型的店目前2026年的这个情况下几乎不可能完成这个呢就是整个的一个流量的一个模式
所以呢我们在日常的这个时操的过程当中呢还可以去提到一个东西叫什么样的一个东西呢就是我们店铺的爆款是可以去做很多但是不建议一个店铺有一个爆款即可啊这个呢就是整个流量给到我们这些运营的方向的一个反思啊所以呢我们接着往下面去跟大家去讲其他的一个内容就是关于流量的类型在这个平台里面呢
流量的类型有哪些呢啊大概率给大家去进行总结了一下一共呢有五个流量那个类型第一个呢是搜索流量搜索流量是什么就像我今天想要去买这支笔是消费者主动发起的行为这个行为在哪里去进行体现呢哎在我们买家端的APP里面去进行体现比如说我想去买一款洗碾金那么这个洗碾金到底是抽的卷的单片的还是什么样的
这个呢叫商家的主动行为主动行为主动行为标签大家这个地方一定要记清楚你的产品的主动行为标签多不多再给大家去举一个很简单的例子我想去买一个手机不是手机壳我想去买个手机我在闲逛的过程当中购买的转换能力高还是我主动去搜索手机苹果17 Pro Max它的行为的转换能力高所以呢在牛腿的转换能力高
牛量的类型里面我们的搜索牛量端里面一般都是主动的行为要大于被动的行为那么被动的行为是什么呢就是推荐的牛量就是被动的行为被动的行为你可以理解为我喜欢逛街就特别是一些女孩子或者你们身边的一些朋友你陪他去进行逛街他进入这个商场里面告诉你我想买一件衣服但是呢他没有很明确的目标但是他会做一件什么事情呢他会进入这个店进入这个店进入这个店不停的去进行
试看 选颜色 选价格 选品牌等等这就是我们在首页里面去进行浏览营销活动页里面去进行浏览在内幕页里面去进行浏览以及在营销资源位里面白衣补贴里面去进行浏览这个呢就是一种被动的行为所以在当下的整个拼多多里面你可以理解为两个流量大的分布是搜索的流量有被动的属性和主动的属性但是推荐流量里面
它的整个主动的行为是非常非常扫的在这个里面给大家一个反思什么样的一个东西呢就是我们在日常的运营的过程当中你上去你一定要很明确的知道你这款产品的流量类型是什么它的主流量在哪里所以我又会提到直通车里面的两个板块成交和ROI出价成交呢一般是优先匹配搜索的主动行为推荐的一般是和ROI去进行匹配
所以呢我们一定要很清楚的去知道这条链接里面整体的行为的标签是什么那么到最后呢会有活动的流量会有付费的流量会有收藏复购等等等等这些流量这些流量呢全部是都是在这两种流量里面那么再给大家去举一个简单易懂的例子就是我在这个里面去进行搜索十链金这个关键词我去买那么给我的整个产品里面的标题的词根是加权的我的人权
人群是加权的我买完以后像我背后我这个人穿黑衣服长得比较帅今年18岁特别喜欢去搜索某个东西的时候哎像我这样的人有多少那么系统会根据我这个产品里面近期类所获取到的标签比如说把我这种人打一个AA级的一个标签对我的某一个产品啊有了这样的一个行为那么我这样背后的这个人呢
和我同属性的这个人你的产品再去做付费的时候啊他会优先展现给我这样的一个人这个呢就是我们有的时候上去会去做一个事情就是去做一些什么指数单啊搜索单啊等等等等这些但是我这个地方给大家去讲一个很重要的东西啊拼多多刷单没有用因为所有东西都会被系统过滤你所看到的都是数字所以呢我提到这个东西有人会说那[来源标识已去除]根据你说的我上去搞几个关键词给我的产品去增加一些啊主动
关键词背后的人群一个差异因为所有的产品的主动行为会大于啊被动行为那么相反主动行为的流量是少的但是呢它的转化啊是高的因为关键词的成交一定是大于推荐的成交的整体的转化能力在拼多多里面这个属于产品的初期阶段那么在产品的中后期的阶段系统就像我刚刚跟大家去
说的会根据这个产品所获取到的人群被动的去推送给需要买这款洗脸金的人群这个你就会从直动车里面去进行代表就是我的出价八元我的限额啊三百元那么我今天开了24小时的车我像这样的直动车一直在去进行投放一直在去进行投放我不动出价不动限额在某一天的时候啊我可能12个小时就烧完了八个小时就烧完了
那么这个地方所产生的一个东西叫订单权重里面所匹配的人在这个地方就会变多这个是整个拼多多里面流量类型给到了我们的一个反思总之一句话所有的产品都只有推荐和搜索的连种流量至于拼多多里面的活动流量付费流量以及收藏复购咨询点击所有的流量都在这连种流量里面去进行包含只是说我们
我们的产品上了活动去进行做付费更容易的原因是因为这些流量在拼多多里面有个东西叫天然有推荐和被推荐人群包
就是拼多多其实在整个直通车板块的时候我会跟大家去讲到一个东西就是拼多多其实是把人分成了369等从年龄地域性别啊收获地址等等
他是把人分成了他只是不想让我们这些商家看到他曾经出过这样的一个人群的一个表格的一个标签
所以拼多多的流量其实分成是很细的还有点的话就是当下的整个拼多多我们获取流量的核心呢其实是在付费里面付费呢是可以去撬动所谓的推荐和搜索的原因是因为我把我的产品的位置推高的情况下我的曝光是大的曝光大被点击的概念就会变大
这个在直通车里面会跟大家去进行讲到但是流量的类型
大家总之记住一句话就是一个核心的点你的产品上去的人群哪一种人群比较大
因为一些冷门的产品只有主动搜索的行为不可能去进行闲逛去进行购买的
你去想一下你陪你的老公老婆女朋友或者是家里面的小孩去商场里面买衣服的行为
你就可以理解为商场里面的某一个店就是你在拼多多里面开的某一个店
这些顾客会进入到你的店铺里面它是一种漫无目的的行为
还有一点的话就是当下的整个拼多多里面推荐的流量是大于搜索流量的A音贝的
具体没有很明确的一个标签
因为当下的整个拼多多流量入口的关系给大家做了一个图
给大家去做了一个图
你可以看到整个平台的流量分成了三个板块
在搜索推荐里面又分成了三个板块
搜索和推荐中间还有个东西叫广告
广告的一个推广
广告的推广里面既有搜索又有推荐
他们是互相去进行影响的
也就是2026年的平台的流量获取的核心是广告推广
并且它互相影响搜索和推荐
还有一个点的话就是它是必要来源
记住是必要来源不是主要更不是部分
因为这个平台里面的所有的广告的流量
你如果一旦停止
你的主要来源和你的部分来源全部都会没有
会直接让你的链接沉入谷底
因为这是当家整个拼多多里面流量的一个结构
同时呢 个性化的流量
举个很简单的例子
我这个产品推荐流量比较多
我去做付费
我的必要流量来源已经拿到了
那么这个时候呢
我想拿到更多的主要来源的推荐流量
这个时候呢
我上秒杀卖9块9和我直接去打强付费9块9
我的直动车出价都是一模一样的情况下
人群包的覆盖的质量
在白衣补贴里面，资源位里面
以及大宿会场里面
它的被点击概率
被转化的概率
以及人群的精准度会更高
所以呢
个性化流量
真正真正的
主要的流量来源的点击转化的能力
是需要有一些资源位的加持的
它会让你的人群质量更高
这个呢
就是很多人在信心念念
在去追求能不能原价上一个活动
能不能去把防比价做好
所以这个是拼多多里面流量的核心
就是很多人问
做拼多多为什么要去做防比价
为什么要去写SKU
为什么要去原价卡达醋
为什么要去做品牌的黑标
为什么要去上秒杀
上9块9
上领券中心
是因为广告流量拿到完之后
激发了推荐流量之后
怎么让我的流量更精准
怎么让我的流量的人群包变大
是需要有资源位的加持的
同时广告流量目前为止只有三个
稳定托管以及明星店铺
直播它属于另外的一种流量池
同时搜索流量里面的核心是
营销活动对搜索也有加权
所以你会发现
整个拼多多里面提到
现在最重要的几个因素
第一个广告流量是核心
营销活动的资源位有加权
记住是加权
同时评分品质
点击的整个转化能力
会影响流量的二次推流
也就是拼多多今年2026年的整个流量的结构
说一句人话就是
开车是必要的
要想让你的直通车越来越优秀
你是需要有营销活动的加权
那么这个地方有人会去问了
营销活动指的是
白补贴大促9块9
领券中心后台报名的吗
不全是
还有限制限量购以及优惠券
以及惊喜券都可以统称为
营销活动的加权
这个呢就是在拼多多的整个后面的实操的过程当中
在成长训练营里面
后期的实操过程当中
我给大家去讲清楚
为什么定价会有三种方式
四种方式
玩法不同
定价不同
这个呢就是整个平台里面流量之间的一种关系
记住
2026年获取整个平台里面
做好拼多多的核心是
需要有广告流量
它是必要
我都没有敢在上面去写唯一来源
因为拼多多还是有部分做低价的
同时呢你是需要用广告流量去激发更多的推荐和搜索流量
还得保持有营销活动的加权和评分以及品质的一个维护
这节课程里面呢
就跟大家去讲到这里
这个呢就是整个平多多里面流量逻辑的一个东西
给大家去最后总结一下
就是平多多的整个店铺的流量属于瀑布式的流量
瀑布式的流量
我们吃的是平台里面
初步冲下来建出的各种小水花的流量
也就是多开店是拼多多所有商家必须要去做
不是考虑的一个问题
你才有可能在这个平台里面做的好
因为它是小水花的店铺
同时呢一个店铺里面不建议大家做太多的单品大爆款
因为爆款和爆款之间会因为一些违规罚款
会影响我另外爆款的生存
所以呢才会有了全店动销
裂便扑货等等等等这些东西
才会有了多开店 多少链接这些东西
还有一点的话就是最后拼多多今年是要求我们既做付费
又要做品质
那么这个品质里面呢
后面会大家就讲到评分的一个环节里面
比的是你在内幕里面的一个东西
也就是我的店铺为什么15%的评分
10%的评分
我一天还能卖个300单500单800单
说明你这个叶子内幕里面选的产品
它本身评分就很差
看你和谁比
记住拼多多里面比的不是自己
比的是同行
也就是在获取流量的过程当中
它也是一种赛马的机制
那么这一节课程呢
就跟大家去讲到这里
我们第二节课程再见